all right so we have a new trailer to a
lab this is the third trailer a
secretary or something like that all I
know is the last trailer people saw
Jeannie and they're like oh oh it's like
Disney either hired a PR company from
millions of dollars listen to YouTube
for free or someone just had an epiphany
in the night woke up from a dream like
Shawn we need to do a shoe the genies
personality crazy
so in this trailer it goes a long way
for public Genie perception or reception
rather that's really what the
concentrate on because for the most part
it's Aladdin you know the story of the
line I know the story of the line and we
all know the story of Aladdin Aladdin
finds a gene he becomes a prince he
doesn't want to tell the princess he's
actually not a prince and the princess
doesn't want to tell Aladdin that she's
actually the pink Power Ranger pink
ranger wears pink just saying I never
cross over on our hands get you the
genie in a second because I'm gonna
talking about what I still don't like
that's too far how old is that dude it
looks pretty [ __ ] I'm just saying
it's less creepy if they hire this young
issue attractive dude to be Jafar be
creepier when it could be her uncle
actually he is old enough to be your
uncle just put his you know is
difference between what is and what it
looks like you know they hired that dude
so people could ship him and Jasmine and
I just don't see him as Jafar well Smith
genie though yeah they did a lot for
this and maybe it's just me maybe I'm
just projecting but when I saw in this
trailer the genies personality I saw him
reacting to what Aladdin was saying I
was reactionary magical quips so what he
was saying I was like okay this does
feel like the genie but not a Robin
Williams ripoff even I guess makes the
Fresh Prince of bel-air reference some
people talking about it online I had to
google it cuz I thought it was just some
weird prince in the background even now
after watching it a few times are we
sure that's a Fresh Prince reference I
feel like that's too vague I feel like
if they were gonna make a Fresh Prince
reference they would have Will Smith in
Fresh Prince as clothing fingers crossed
they don't want to spoil it in the
trailer they're saving it for the movie
and Will Smith actually becomes Fresh
Prince in the foreground not a vague
reference in the background it's all
about if that the studio rights to it
they might not is that to call himself
Fresh Prince it's just
Will Smith wearing 90s clothing no one's
saying otherwise a lot less blue Will
Smith GT in this trailer a lot more
regular Will Smith Jeannie which is
funny because the Entertainment Weekly
cover came out people like no that's not
the Jeannie and the trailer came out
people are like no that's not the chief
fine here's Will Smith Jeannie again as
he was presented on Entertainment Weekly
all right that's better my just listen
to us Disney huh you know some of the
musical numbers in here never had
like me a whole new world worked away
from this trailer having a good time
with the trailer it's more the curiosity
aspect an element I want to see what
they translate from the animation to the
live-action how they do it so do I need
it no but after this trailer I don't
hate it so my thoughts the new trailer
in Aladdin they did what they should
have done the first time which is show
the genies personality that's the
important thing is big blueness I don't
care especially when the big blueness is
pretty unimpressive at the end of all of
it if it all sucks
still got the animation still amazing
alright so the new trailer for a lot and
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]